hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar cancer cells send signals
boosting survival and drug resistance in
other cancer cells presented by dr.
Jeffery rod Wald a post doctoral
researcher at UC San Diego i'm susie
valdez and i will be your moderator for
this educational webinar presented by
lab roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that green Q&A button located at the
lower left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also notice
you'll be viewing this presentation in a
slide window to enlarge that window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or use
that Q&A button and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits click on the button in
the bottom left hand corner and follow
the process to obtain your credits I'd
now like to introduce today's speaker
dr. Jeffery rod well Jeff is an expert
in tumor microenvironment biology
currently they both postdoctoral
researcher he completed his PhD in
biomedical sciences at UC San Diego
focusing on the unfolded protein
response within the tumor
microenvironment his research involved
elucidating how the tumor micro
environment becomes dysregulated within
both the cancer cell and the immune
infiltrate compartment through the
production of signaling molecule cancer
cells producing during the UPR he earned
his BS invite engineering from UC San
Diego in 2010 where he performed
research in the field of biomaterials
and stem cell Meccano transduction
please join me in welcoming dr. Jeffery
rod well I
now turn the presentation over to him
welcome Jeff
great thank you very much Susie for that
introduction and thank you too Thermo
Fisher Scientific for the opportunity
today to talk to you about the cell
extrinsic consequences of the tumor UPR
there a title called cancer cells send
signal eliciting survival and drug
resistance in other cancer cells my name
is Jeff raveled I'm a postdoctoral
scientist at UC San Diego in the Zanetti
lab where our research today has been
where the data of today's research has
been found in today's talk what I'd like
to do is first provide an introduction
to the endoplasmic reticulum ER stress
and the unfolded protein response i will
then introduce how the UPR is involved
in the tumor microenvironment as a cell
intrinsic driver towards tumor growth
I will then extrapolate these findings
by providing evidence that there are
cell extrinsic consequences of the tumor
UPR through a phenomenon called
transmissible ER stress or Turse I'll
introduce the choice hypothesis and
review how we designed a culture
technique in vitro to generate the
conditioned media revealing this
phenomenon in some detail I'll review
our studies concerning myeloid cells and
the effects of Turse on myeloid cells
specifically macrophages and dendritic
cells and how they're polarized to an
inflammatory and immune suppressive
phenotype and provide evidence that this
phenotype can be recovered in vivo
finally with more detail I'll be
reviewing how turist affects cancer
cells specifically how it in doubt cited
protection when signaling the mechanism
behind both of these phenomenon and
demonstrate that clonal fitness can
occur both in vitro and in vivo through
the effects of Turse and without further
ado let's jump right into it the
endoplasmic reticulum is a massive and
sprawling organelle found in all cells
it's responsible for the proper folding
maturation and secretion of nascent
polypeptide chains as they become
shelled from one
from within the ER to the specific
organelle of interest in this way the ER
is a massive and sprawling organelle
necessary to traffic protein throughout
all compartments of the cell you can
appreciate in the right hand figure that
this network looks awfully like a
highway system and the there's plenty of
end of an analogy between the two
specifically the ER can accommodate an a
massive amount of cargo at any one time
a massive amount of proteins can be
properly folded matured and trafficked
out of the ER without there being any
issues but as a Southern Californian as
many others are very familiar traffic is
never homeostatic and in fact often
traffic jams can occur that looks often
like this the biologic significance of
traffic jams is an accumulation of myths
or unfolded protein that sit in the ER
that can be a consequence of a variety
of insults to cope with your stress
cells initiate the unfolded protein
response the UPR in eukaryotes this
evolutionarily conserved phenomenon is
mediated by three transmembrane proteins
perc re1 alpha and atf six they're held
in an inactive state through their
associations with a master chaperone
protein called GRP 78 however when
there's an accumulation of mr. unfolded
protein GFP 78 preferentially
dissociates from these transmembrane
proteins and to aid in its chaperone
function of folding polypeptide chains
in so doing it depresses each of these
three arms to allow for downstream
effects perc dimerizes and auto
phosphorylates ultimately promoting the
activation of the activating
transcription factor 4 or ACF for seen
here which provides generally speaking a
pro apoptotic signaling through its
induction of a probiotic protein chopped
iru an alpha oligomers and auto
phosphorylates its primary function is
an endonuclease function
where it cleaves the where it spices the
xbp one mrna leading to a spliced
isoform of this mRNA leading to the
production of the transcription factor
XB p1 which serves to restore ER
homeostasis as well as preferentially
activate a variety of genes a cf6
translocates to the golgi where it is
modified to an active form where it then
serves as an as a transcription factor
itself again aiding in the are in
balancing homeostasis within the ER one
of the compelling features of the UPR is
it is neither strictly pro apoptotic nor
strictly pro survival but depending on
the duration and the amount of ER stress
that occur these three arms will decide
whether self should go through apoptosis
or persevere and survive for this reason
the UPR has been implicated in a variety
of pathologies including neuro
degeneration diabetes and in fact cancer
one of the prime locations for this to
occur is within the tumor
microenvironment
the tumor microenvironment is a awful
mess of cells both of transformed and
non transformed nature as represented in
the left cartoon the self-interested
cancer self have no interest in creating
a balance vasculature this in turn leads
to exogenous stressors such as epoxy ax
nutrient deprivation and acidic pH all
of which create ER stress indeed there
are also endogenous stressors within
cancer cells that can cause a are stress
such as aneuploidy there's numerous
lines of evidence to suggest that the
UPR is involved in cell intrinsic
features to lead to tumor Anisa T of
various solid malignancies including xB
t1 g RP 78 and perc in a variety of
different tissues most of these studies
have been focused on how the UPR
provides cell intrinsic benefits
predominantly through signaling
pro-survival pathways as well as lead to
metastatic function we sought to
demonstrate that there could also be
cell extrinsic consequences of the tumor
UPR specifically as an initial
hypothesis that there is in effect on
the immune infiltrate of the tumor
microenvironment through cell extrinsic
wins concept so extrinsic part in the
features of the tumor UPR to that end
strictly our hypothesis became that
there exists tumor cell born skews
produced by UPR signaling that
extrinsically effect infiltrating cells
or cells within the tumor
microenvironment to that end it was
important for us to establish an in
vitro setting where we could very easily
control all of the factors and model
some of these stimuli in a very
controlled manner the conclusion of our
studies as I will review today
demonstrate that a phenomenon known as
transmissible er stress affects both
immunity as well as resident cancer
cells to opposite facilitate tumor
outgrow I will be reviewing in some
brief detail our key findings on it
innate immunity as it relates to torus
which comes from two main publications
the first concerned with the roles of
turrets on macrophages the second
concerned with the effects of Turse on
dendritic cells and thereby adaptive
immunity and then finally in greater
detail we'll be discussing how
transmissible air stress affects cancer
cells in order to establish an
experimental model based off of our
hypothesis we have to consider some
requirements the first and foremost is
we wanted to demonstrate the cancer
cells of various origin undergoing air
stress must produce some molecule in
order to do that it was important for us
that we could control for the stress of
a transmitting cell is producing a
molecule
has been carried over to a recipient
cell as opposed to just loading cells
with a drug result taking the the
resulting condition media still
containing the drug and loading it on to
recipient cells which becomes far more
precarious when you're trying to
deconvolution tribution
are made by the transmitting cell and
what contributions are made simply
because of drug carryover of course the
system also had to be affordable rapid
and reproducible the model that we
designed was the following
we took tumour cells of various origin
and seeded them in a about 80%
confluency and created ER stress through
the treatment of the drug fafsa Gargan
fafsa Gargan is a seraph inhibitor that
effectively depletes the ER full of
calcium out of out of calcium leading to
creating ER stress because of this it
allows us to you treat cells for an
acute length of time in our hands a 300
and animal or concentration for two
hours which depletes the ER of calcium
in so doing we then wash twice to remove
any residual or unmetabolized
drug of fafsa Gargan and then load onto
these treated cells with standard growth
media as you'll find in subsequent
slides in addition to the TG treated
cells we use vehicle conditioned media
as a control to control for any effects
that are just carried over simply by the
cancer cells in a homeostatic
environment in both cases we harvest 16
hours later we result we harvest the
conditioned media by by filtering it
through a point to 2 micron filter and
then load it onto naive cells in our
initial experiments we loaded this on
two unstressed j77 for mirroring
macrophages and what we were surprised
with finding from foremost was in fact
that ER stress was that the macrophage
is treated with this condition media
underwent ER stress which is to say our
stress was being transmitted from a
tumor cell to a macrophage cell and thus
the at V term transmissible er stress or
terse in revealing
a large collection of data what I'd like
to draw your attention to is the
following
send that the synoptic review of a bunch
of experiments whereby we took cancer
cells of various origin here you're
looking at tramps one which are a murine
prostate cancer cell line and we treated
bone marrow derived macrophages with the
vehicle or Tris conditioned media of
tram c1 cells after 24 during for 24
hours you'll notice the first three
panels include ER stress related genes
ERP 78 x BP 1 s and shop where they all
had an increased transcriptional up
regulation in addition these cells
became pro-inflammatory through the
increases of inflammatory genes aisle 6
Aisle 23 and CNF alpha our studies also
showed that these molecules could be
produced and secreted as well and are
not just affected at the transcriptional
level perhaps most striking however is
that cells also acquired a suppressive
feature through the up regulation of our
Genesis 1 an immune suppressive molecule
that restrains t-cell proliferation
we used various cell lines including
during lung cell carcinoma llc's or
nearing melanoma cell lines all of which
had similar effects though there was
some biologic variability in terms of 10
terms of recipient cells we've also used
immortalized j77 for cells and bone
marrow derived macrophages where again
we find a similar phenomenon to be true
we then were interested in demonstrating
that the phenomenon that we described is
not exclusively due to fafsa Gargan
mediated ER stress to that end we took
different cancer cell lines including
transy 1b 16 in LLC and starved them of
glucose both in the growth media as well
as using dialyzed FBS which had a
molecular cutoff that it was able to
remove glucose and we treated pre
treated these cancer cells for 24 hours
in the absence of glucose effectively
creating ER stress we then
this condition media and treated
macrophages with either this condition
media or either standard growth media
denoted as our PMI plus or glucose
starved media itself our PMI - as you
appreciate in the the transcriptional
data on the right you'll find that these
cells macrophages had increases in you
PR related genes in the top row ERP 78
gap 34 in chop both wouldn't they
themselves underwent nutrient
deprivation in the second panel but they
had substantially increased ER stress
when they were treated with the nutrient
deprived media precondition by the
various cancer cell types concordantly
they were also polarized to a
pro-inflammatory state meaning that
there were seem to be some other factor
to enhance and potentiate the effects of
the glucose deprivation to this end we
concluded that transmissible ER stress
could occur through the the very
relevant tumor microenvironment 'el
insult glucose deprivation indeed the
profile that I've described to you is
neither classically m1 or m2 but in fact
terse treated myeloid cells acquired
this mixed phenotype that is both
pro-inflammatory an immune suppressive
of equal interest is the fact that a
separate group at University of
Washington in 2012 showed that veg F was
also produced using similar techniques
to what we described today meaning in
fact that these cells are both
pro-inflammatory immune suppressive and
angiogenic we then wanted to receipt if
this profile this terse profile as I
described which is both ER stress
inflammatory and immune suppressive
exists within the tumor microenvironment
to that end we use two different models
an orthotopic model which involved
mirroring melanoma be 16 cells
subcutaneously injected into an immune
competent host in the second model a
spontaneous model in which we used a pc
mice which develop small intestinal
adenoma at about three months of age and
both models we harvested the myeloid
info
from both the tumor as well as the
spleen and bone marrow where we would
predict er stress is not nearly as
commonly occurring as it is within the
tumor microenvironment we then perform
qpcr of the CD 11 B+ the myeloid
positive infiltrate what we found was
that in both models the CT 11 B+ cells
that infiltrated the tumor
microenvironment had transcriptional
increases in ER stress genes
inflammatory genes and immune
suppressive genes relative to those of
the splenic our bone marrow drive
controls confirming that the profile
that we were able to demonstrate so
cleanly in vitro existed in vivo to that
end our working hypothesis of how
transmissible ER stress may affect
immune infiltrate is the following in
the absence of the arc stress cancer
cells it properly able to coordinate a
pre cancer cells are able to properly
coordinate was infiltrating an antigen
presenting cells including macrophages
and introduced up a coordinate this with
t lymphocytes to lead to clonal
expansion of the adaptive arm of
immunity ultimately clean being any pre
malignant lesion however in the presence
of ER stress cancer cells are per se
able to transmit factors or a factor
that affects infiltrating immune
infiltrate macrophage or dendritic cell
which in turn suppresses any adaptive
arm through the production of Arjun ace
as well as the surface trans okay its
surface expression of PDL one which I
didn't have time to review today as well
as the production of pro-inflammatory
cytokines including il-6 il-23
and of course the angiogenic factor
digest all of these converge in which to
enable the tumor to grow and escape from
immune surveillance that left us
wondering though do the cell extrinsic
effects of the UPR affect unstressed
cancer cells it's well and good to
describe the phenomenon that I've
introduced to you but in fact we're
overlooking the majority population of
the tumor which is to say other cancers
and so we were left wondering what
effects curse might have on neighboring
cancer cells which is to say if 1,000
they're going to ER stress because of
either lack of nutrients or lack of
oxygen or defects that lead to exogenous
or endogenous defects such as the
aneuploidy how would that affect a
neighboring cancer cell that is
otherwise homeostatic and it's protein
folding we drew inspiration from a
provocative paper published in 2014 from
the polio group in the journal Nature
who challenged this classical idea that
clonal dynamics within the tumor
microenvironment are driven and cell
autonomous manners and the the the
paradigm that once existed that a cell
acquires a driver mutation and then
becomes the predominant clone the polite
group challenge this by showing that in
fact in a cell not in a non cell
autonomous manner
when you control for any changes in
genetic lineage there still is a dynamic
influence of different sub clones within
the tumor microenvironment which is to
say during times of tumor development
one clone a clone a may be the
predominant clone but during times of
chemotherapy or through any temporal
imbalance clones B C P or Z would be the
predominant clone the conclusion of
these of this paper was in fact that
tumor growth could be sustained by minor
cell populations and acted in a Cell non
autonomous manner well leaving us to
hypothesize that tirst could drive tumor
clonal heterogeneity and provides tumor
cell fitness to that end we used human
prostate cancer cells as a model just so
we could focus on one specific tissue
the research being done today was
predominantly using PC 3 cells lenten
capsules and d1 4-5 cells and
first experiment that we performed we
produced vehicle or Tris conditioned
media using our classical FAFSA Guardian
method and pc3 cells harvested the
conditioned media and loaded onto
unstressed gc3 cells what we find in
panels a and B is in fact these cells
were underwent substantial er stress
throughout the five-day treatment of B
conditioned media we did resettlement
every other day for these conditions to
occur and we found that in fact these
cells were able the cells that did
survive had substantial ER stress
concordantly however this was not
restricted to a like cells but
heterogeneous cells as well which is to
say we could generate terse using a PC 3
line and load it on CD 1 4 or 5 cells as
we did did in panel C where again you
find a similar trend occurs the
conclusion of which is transmissible
yard stress is certainly not restricted
to just affecting innate immunity but in
fact neighboring cancer cells and it's
not restricted of course therefore two
alike clones additionally these cells
acquired pro-inflammatory features
there's such as the increase of il-6 and
as I described they had an increase in
the master chaperone protein ERP 78 both
intracellularly as visualized in panel E
but also at the cell surface as
visualized in panel F by flow cytometry
this is particularly striking because
the surface relocation of GRP 78 which
still remains to be a controversial
topic in the field of the UPR has been
implicated in to merge Anisa t in a
variety of solid malignancies such that
it's become a druggable target in
various models and is suggested to
provide a new moniker perhaps monoclonal
intervention against it in terms of our
kinetics we notice that surface GRP 78
didn't occur the relocation of surface
trapeze I mean they didn't occur on day
1 but it took a protracted period of
time on day 3 and
even substantially on day five
suggesting that this is not an acute
experience that the cells must undergo
but something that must be a little bit
more protracted this little saw
theorized that in fact that first could
operate within a iterative manner within
the tumor microenvironment and so to
better illustrate these effects what we
decided to do was treat cells for two
days on either vehicle or tourist
conditioned media represented here we
then would remove the purse or vehicle
conditioned media washing twice and then
resettlement with standard growth media
for two days off during this time the
treated cells could restore their ER and
restore homeostatic function again the
belief being if a cancer cell is
producing these factors it likely is not
a faucet fully on all the time but is
turned on and off this population we
refer to as terse primed or vehicle
primed interestingly thirst prime cells
had a surface relocation of GRP 7da
that was quite profound relative to
vehicle prime cells because of this and
the role of surface GRP 78 and enabling
tumour cell survival we then wanted to
look at how this might affect cells
during one of the most common insults of
the tumor microenvironment which again
is glucose deprivation so we starved
vehicle primed or terse prime cells for
48 hours and the first two panels you'll
appreciate the we have is our negative
control using just complete growth media
while in the latter two we've starved
the cells of glucose and FBS jerky 78
was increased at both the unstimulated
and stimulated conditions conversely the
perc arm which we considered to be the
pro apoptotic arm was repressed or had a
less expression in the terse prime
population than the vehicle prime
population drawing your attention to the
fact that eighth of atf
or and chop had markedly reduced
expression in the terse prime cells
during nutrient deprivation these two
observations increases in geography 78
and altered perk signaling would suggest
that the cells might be surviving better
within the glucose starvation to that
end we starved cells for glue for 48
hours as previously described and then
probed them for viability by an X and 5
apoptosis assay by flow cytometry as you
can appreciate for those who may not be
familiar with how to read these assays
it's presented in the lower right hand
corner where you have your live cells in
the lower left and the lower right
quadrant are your dying cells and in
your upper right quadrant are your dead
cells first prime cells survived about
two or about three times as much as
their vehicle prime cords as you can
appreciate 27 percent versus 66 percent
survival after 48 hours if we carried
the starvation out for another day it
could be as compelling as 40% relative
to 2% we were really excited by this
data but we wondered if the cells also
were protected against doggedness
insults not just those that are
contained within the tumor
microenvironment to that end we use the
stress inducing chemotherapy bortezomib
which is a proteasome inhibitor that
creates massive amounts of ER stress to
ultimately drive er its tumor cell death
again across the titration of the drug
we find that GRP 78 is increased
whereas perfectly again remains altered
concordantly we observed vehicle prime
cells had poorer survival relative to
terse prime cells across the titration
of the drug for instance at 100
nanomolar
we have 75 percent survival of tris
prime cells relative to 38% in vehicle
prime cells we were satisfied with these
results but we wanted to know if this
was a durable side of protection or
simply lost after two days and so using
GRP 78 abundance as a proxy for site of
protection we detected its changes
between the change
is an expression between vehicle and tur
stem cells two days post priming and up
to five days post priming in which the
cells had not experienced any
transmissible TR stress condition media
for one week again
you can appreciate that we had increases
in fact in ERP 78 and the tur stem cells
this concordantly was found to have the
site of protective where we could again
find increases interest primed cells
treated with bortezomib over vehicle
from cells however produce women
additions are not always done with solid
malignancy and so we wondered if non
stress inducing chemotherapy also was
less effective interest prime cells we
used the microtubule inhibitor
paclitaxel which in our hands causes no
ER stress in cells to see if we could
find a similar phenomenon I'll be quick
to point out at this point that others
have reported that pathway paxil can
cause BR stress particularly in ovarian
cancer but in our hands here is shown in
panels a B and C we found that no ER
stress could be produced at the
transcriptional level in a or at the
protein level in the Western blot sperm
in B and C however here again we find
that terse prime cell survive better
than their vehicle prime cohort I'll
draw your attention to the fact that we
have 23 percent death in vehicle prime
cells relative to 6 percent death
interest for him cells because
paclitaxel is mediating cytotoxicity
through creating double-stranded DNA
breaks by preventing a proper
microtubule assembly we wondered if
there was any change in the cell cycle
and in fact we find that there is a
change in the G to M phase where DNA
repair occurs whereby Tris prime cells
were enriched somewhere between two to
threefold relatives of vehicle prime
cells
it's importantly if we probe for
double-stranded DNA breaks and
paclitaxel vehicle primed or Tris prime
cells we find this is in IHC staining
for gamma h2ax
which stains double-stranded DNA breaks
you again find a market differ
pattern between the two suggestive of
the fact that trim cells are not
undergoing double-stranded DNA breaks
induced by paclitaxel we couldn't quite
explain this phenomenon in Richmond the
g2m phase due to ER stress however one
pathway that's incriminated into merge
Anisa T and in the arisen in the g2m
phase is wind signaling so we did PCR
for the abundance of two genes
associated with wind signaling both beta
catenin and it's negative regulator
action - and we found that the
protracted treatment of vehicle of
choice Prime's condition media I should
say and these pc3 cells analyzed here
was increased relative to vehicle
condition media to better visualize and
appreciate the kinetics of this
phenomenon we took advantage of a
reporter system called the TCF optimal
promoter or top promoter assay in which
when beta catenin is stabilized ready
leading to when signaling it associates
with a complex including TCF leading to
downstream signaling and activation of
winds associated genes the top reporter
takes advantage of this by putting a GFP
transcript downstream of this assembly
so we could detect GFP expression by
flow cytometry in top transduced cells
to associate how Tris conditioned media
effects when signaling and panel C as
you can see on the two days off of tryst
conditioned media we had robust wint
signaling relative to vehicle
conditioned media concluding that when
sig that terse promotes when signaling
to understand the mechanism behind this
we treated cells in the absence or
presence of vehicle or terse conditioned
media with the addition of in panel C
and I re one and HIPAA chemical
inhibitor for MUHC
or in the case of panel D a perk
inhibitor GSK two six five six one five
seven whereas perk inhibition had no
effect on top expression visualized in
panel D the ire1 inhibitor did
suggesting that i re one inhibition
mediated by tercet effects
an effect on when signaling in court we
wanted to know if this phenomenon was
restricted to simply er stress-related
effects or terse related effects we then
treated cells with Tunica myosin and
probe for pop expression where we could
find no changes in top GFP product
despite the fact that the cells will
underwent ER stress suggested of the
fact that the effects of tourists on
when signaling are privileged and not
generalizable ter stress importantly a
recent paper and oncogenes from a
separate group reported that I re one
seems to be involved in wind signaling
we then wanted to deconvolution ISM is
responsible for its site of protective
effects we've observed predicting that
the UPR was centrally involved we
decided to go to a mouse embryonic
fibroblasts or meth model and panel a we
first demonstrated that the priming
model of Terce could exist in mass where
you find increases in protection in both
bortezomib tactile and nutrient
deprivation however abandoning wild-type
mass for pop perc knockout maps we find
that we can no longer recover this side
of protection I'll point out that we've
also done these studies using IR u1
alpha and a CF 6 knockout maps where the
pattern is less reproduce less
compelling but they do have equally
contributing roles to this phenomenon to
better demonstrate however that perk was
involved we decided to use leverage
CRISPR technology and panel C you can
see our guide against exon 2 of ATF for
one of the central targets of perk
signaling in panel D you see successful
deletion of alteration of the ATF for
construct and in panel e using 2 9 3 T
cells you see again using wild-type
cells we have prime cells that have sign
up protection during terse and down
features however using ATF or CRISPR 2 9
3 T cells the side protective effects
are long
suggestive again that perk signalling
and perhaps particularly ATF for our
central and decided protective effects
that we've observed bringing it back to
our opening hypothesis which is that
clonal heterogeneity and clonal fitness
could they be endowed by terse we took
advantage of a murine tagging model
whereby we transduced tramps t1 cells
with rfp that would considerably express
red fluorescent protein and we primed
them with translate one vehicle
conditioned media separately we terse
primed untagged [ __ ] c1 cells we then
Co cultured these two populations
together and challenged them for 24
hours with a variety of insults and by
flow cytometry determined the relative
abundance of rfp positive and rfp
negative cells what we find is that
across a variety of challenges including
fafsa Guardian to deoxy d glucose which
serves as a model for nutrient
starvation or glucose starvation port
azimuth and tax all the tourists primed
clone always emerged as the fit clone if
we reverse the conditions which is to
say [ __ ] c 1rf peed cells archers Prime
and untagged trim c1 cells our vehicle
primed we find the same results
concordantly if we took [ __ ] c1 cells
and vehicle prime them or Tris primed
them and contralaterally injected them
into an immune competent host we were
curious as to how this might affect
tumor growth which we observed over one
month's time what we find is that terse
primed tumors grew at much faster rates
than their vehicle primed cohort after
one month's time in panel D you can see
there's a substantial change in tumor
weight and you'll have to forgive in
panel either gross the gross morphology
of these tumors at the time I was quite
experienced at removing tumors from
tumor bearing mice the conclusion of our
studies however is the following that in
the absence of ER stress there could be
or of any challenge there could be these
sub
populations in blue that are tourists
primed however the introduction of a
chemotherapy or a tumor microenvironment
and pressure would force the clonal
dynamics to change whereby a naive
cancer cell may die from these
challenges where as a tourist
experienced cancer cell there is
increases in gfp 78 both intracellularly
and at the cell surface increases in
wind signaling and altered perk
signaling all enabled to cope with these
insults to ultimately emerge as the
predominant clone within the tumor
microenvironment the conclusion of these
studies are the following therefore
using in vitro systems we were able to
provide a precise tool to recreate some
of the stimuli that may be native to the
tumor microenvironment
I'll point out that our observations in
vitro and in vivo were only enabled or
rather I should say are in vivo
observations were predicated off of the
observations in vitro so again using
conditioned media allowed us to de
convolute
a very challenging problem that would be
very difficult to solve using mouse
models or more advanced models and then
finally I hope today I've convinced you
that transmissible er stress Dulli
effects cancer cells as well as innate
immunity all of which these features
seem to converge to enable tumor cell
growth I'll conclude by revisiting the
Hanahan and Weinberg hallmarks of cancer
in which they outlined that there are
ten features that tumor cells must
acquire for their successful outgrowth
in today's talk and through some
features I haven't had time to review
with you today transmissible er stress
seems to affect at least six of these
programs today I put particular emphasis
on resisting cell death deregulating
cellular energetic energetics the
survival of glucose deprivation I've
introduced observations that effect
angiogenesis tumor promoting
inflammation and indeed avoiding immune
destruction and data I didn't have time
to review today there
also seems to be effects on replicative
important allottee by affecting
telomerase reverse transcriptase
orchards with that I'd like to conclude
by first thanking the members of the
Zanetti lab and predominantly Naveen
Mahadevan who was the original mind that
laid out a lot of these experiments in
the Len lab Jonathan H Lin's lab at UC
San Diego Nobu hiramatsu was tremendous
helpful a tremendous help to understand
how transmissible ER stress is affecting
cancer cells and finally I would like to
again reiterate my appreciation to
Thermo Fisher Scientific for this great
opportunity to talk to you today about
the effects of transmissible our stress
and with that I'm looking forward to
fielding your questions and look forward
to the dialogue thank you very much
the red bulb for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appear on the screen
and click the send button for answer as
many questions as we have time for today
so let's take a look at our audience
members questions that are already
coming in a first question whether I bow
is to all cancer cell lines experience
the same level of terse provided saito
protection and a second part of that is
what about production of Tourister ok
yeah it's a fair question so to answer
the first one do all cancer cell lines
experience the same level side of
protection the answer is not all at the
same level I would say that most of the
data we saw today was from PC 3 cells
and in the paper that we described we
also looked at Len capsules India one
four five cells where again we do find
the same phenomenon is true that they're
protected obviously it was most
pronounced in the tc3 cells and we do
think that this must be some sort of
generalizable phenomenon as we've been
able to do it with breast cancer cell
lines mirroring [ __ ] sees outline you
saw some of the data using meth cells
and 293 t-cells so we don't think it's
quite restricted to just one particular
line but of course like anything else
some lines are better at it than others
and I think the same could be said for
tours production if you recall and I
think it was one of the earlier slides
that we did I introduced where we talk
where we treat these cells with a
variety here we are where we use [ __ ]
c1 cells these 16 cells in LLC cells you
can appreciate that
in the each has the same production
effects that is to say they all transmit
ER stress how
for the levels of ER stress seem to be a
little variable from one line to the
next
so we do think that this is a
programming that most cells if not all
cells can do but some might do it better
than others thank you and here's our
next question
this terse treatment cause any cytotoxic
effects on tested cell lines yes that is
a fair point it definitely can when
you're protract
for the length of time that we have done
these even for the two days on or the
iterative every other day for five days
you do can have a certain percent of
cell death we've observed this can be
anywhere between twenty to forty percent
at the time of these and our in vitro
models we had some cells that were that
we were provided that were unhealthy
that these effects were then pronounced
even further to 80% to 90% death
obviously we didn't use those because
they were contaminated but yes there are
cytotoxic effects that could be observed
and again while that may seem artificial
it's not too surprising given the fact
that this likely would occur in the
tumor microenvironment and if you see
terse almost as a Darwinian effect that
is to say that there are some are going
to survive and some will thrive the ones
that do thrive seem to thrive very well
so yeah I think that there could be
cytotoxic effects but the ones that
persevere are really the the concerning
clones thank you and thank you to our
audience members what a wonderful live
participation we have today here's our
next question can you further discuss
how you see terse effects to our
immunity sure yeah if I understand the
question correctly the question is kind
of how we see this effect or some unit
or how you know immunity and I think
they probably were talking about
adaptive immunity
here at how triskin affected um you know
through a paper that we I didn't have
time to discuss today but I'll jump onto
this slide where by let's see here we
are so whereby we kind of see that there
are a variety of effects that can occur
on this t-cell on the far right through
the predator my predecessor Naveen mod
Dave and he did a lot of this work he's
really capable demonstrating that these
T cells become energic when experienced
with myeloid cells that had been treated
with terse which is to say that the T
cells aren't able to clonally expand and
aren't able to clear any tumour the
effects of Church directly on T cells is
something that we're really interested
in that we haven't had time to go into
any great length but we do think that
there could be effects on promoting
either T reg function or something to
that effect so we do think it could
affect adaptive immunity as well but
currently our understanding is that the
kind of a fulcrum of this between his
tumor cell to myeloid cell and the
myeloid sell pizza to the adaptive arm
so yeah I think hopefully that answered
the question but we do think that there
are effects on adaptive immunity
certainly thank you dr. Rodwell
and what percent of oxygen was used
during in-vitro culture rome oxic or
hypoxic so we've used norm oxic
conditions for the studies that i
presented today we just did norm oxic
cultures and the reason is because we
just wanted to we wanted to control for
any other bystander effects like epoxy
a-- that certainly would occur within
the tumor microenvironment
but we didn't want to make it assignable
to this i will say however we have been
able to generate tours like effects with
hypoxia where we pre incubated these
lines the
transy one LLC lines in a epoxy
environment in which we used 0.5 percent
oxygen for 48 hours and then normalized
oxygen levels and then loaded it onto
receiver macrophages where we find
similar effects I really want to do if I
understand the question correctly I
would love to have done an experiment
where we show how this affects hypoxic
conditions as well however we didn't
have access to a incubator to
demonstrate that but I would be willing
to bet that some of the cytoprotective
effects that I've talked about with
nutrient deprivation are also
experienced in a hypoxic setting as well
thank you and what can you tell about
the identity of the phenomenon yeah so
there's scant information in today's
talk about that because in truth we
haven't been able to fully identify it
that's something near and dear to our
heart and something that every day we're
working towards what I can say right now
is the molecule is not a protein it
doesn't it seems to be a small molecule
we think it's a lipid of some sort the
you know without saying exactly what it
is obviously because we don't know truly
its identity I would say it's in really
low abundance and that's made it
particularly difficult for identity
efforts we've paired up with a organic
chemist at Scripps Institute of
Oceanography and they're kind of helping
us out with these isolation techniques
using HPLC chromatographic techniques
and NMR and mass spec however any
ambition we had of it being just a
transmitted protein does not seem to be
the case and I'd also like to point out
that in some sense it may not even be
one factor and in fact I would emphasize
the wint story on
kind of evidence for that where we don't
think at least personally I don't think
that while we know that went protein is
not responsible for the wind signaling
effects it's certainly likely that there
could be other transmitted molecules
that in one sense endow er stress or pro
inflammation and other produced factors
that either stimulate went signaling or
angiogenic or immune suppressive effects
so obviously each of those are separate
questions but in terms of the factor
that seems to transmit ER stress right
now we think it's a small signaling
lipid thank you and why do you think
this phenomenon you described occurs in
meth yeah that's also a fine question to
ask which is something that you know at
the time we used mess just as a one of
them are clean and elegant models to
address the question of what effects are
or what arm of the UPR seems to mediate
the side of protection we observe um in
terms of the Y maps would be able to
transmit er stress and have gains inside
a protection that's what obviously a
larger question but I think it speaks to
potentially the fact that this
transmissible event that we're
describing may be evolutionarily
conserved I know that's kind of a bold
statement but there was a series of
reports that came from Andy Dylan's
group currently now at UC Berkeley where
he used C elegans and was able to
demonstrate that if you were to create
er stress in neuronal lines or neuronal
tissue it affected bounce other organ
systems organ systems as well meaning
that there seems to be some effect that
was being transmitted from one cell line
to another in C elegans that ultimately
promoted longevity and those organisms
so that's kind of a stretch to go from C
elegans to Macedon to say that the same
phenomenon could be true but if it were
to be true it would suggest that this is
a conserved event that probably was once
used for good purposes as demonstrated
and what it can do to C elegans and like
a lot of other programming the cancer
cells hi jacket for their own benefit
for survival and it's really only when
you can produce these stimuli which we
think would only really occur in chaotic
environments like the tumor micro
environment or in during times of severe
stress that their signals would occur
that make it relevant so I kind of got
off on tangent there but I think the
reason why we ultimately use Maps is
because they're a clean model and they
likely just have the programming and
Nate in them as any other cell line does
thank you dr. Rodwell
and we have time for one final question
because I want to give you some time for
final comments I want to thank our
audience again and remind them that any
questions not answer today will be
answered via email following the
presentation so here's our final
question for today what do you think the
implications of terse are in relation to
different lines of intervention like for
example radiation or chemotherapy or
even surgery for that matter sure um so
I think the the point of our study of
the the latter study that we talked
about here is to provide a new line of
consideration of how cells might adapt
to standard lines of chemotherapy
obviously chemo resistance is a topic
that a lot of people are familiar with
and we're trying to provide evidence
that these this site sited protective
effects might be through cell
non-autonomous manners and so I suppose
for chemotherapy the first point I would
make is that if you're to intervene
using standard chemotherapy you might
also want to consider intervening
against the UPR or ER stress or you know
when the time does come that we identify
the factor to intervene against that
factor that seems to be endowing these
features in terms of how this would
affect radiation that's a great question
and it's something we've never really
broached though I would have be really
interested in those studies and then in
terms of surgery I recall a few papers
that have been produced in various
groups I think one at Andy Anderson
whose name is escaping me to show that
surgery obviously can cause a massive
amount of stress as well on a patient
and that that stress in turn can
actually do more harm than good
so it would be interesting to see if the
stress associated with you know someone
cutting into you and removing a tumor
may in fact have effects in producing
this molecule which kind of reinvigorate
the transmissible er stress phenomenon
and in fact kind of put a little bit of
gasoline on the effects so I would say
that that could definitely be area
future topic as we kind of transition
from our basic and vitro models to more
clinically relevant in vivo models see I
suppose that would be my final point on
that Thank You dr. rod called did you
want to provide our audience with any
final comment before we close today sure
so I would obviously conclude by first
of all reiterating this opportunity from
thermo Fisher Scientific to give today's
talk I do hope that if anything the
point would be to say that we've tried
to provide a new line of mechanism that
might be occurring within the tumor
microenvironment mediated by ER stress
and we certainly don't think that this
is the end-all be-all of how the tumor
microenvironment operates but i hope it
provides the audience with a new line of
consideration and then of course I would
love if anyone had any further questions
on today's talk on that as it comes to
them I would love to feel those so feel
free to email me for any further
curiosities that might strike you I
think my emails attached but if not I'll
just reiterate it as a JJ rod Fuld at
gmail.com and again I'd love to hear you
guys have thoughts or hopefully this
will provide as a template for further
investigation yeah that would be my
concluding thought thank you dr. rod
Gould and I'd like to also take the
opportunity to thank lab roots and our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting us know
that the webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and thanks for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye